hello everybody and welcome to the next
part of let's play penumbra the Black
Plague I don't even remember I don't
even remember Oh anyway that's good here
I adore Oh OOP that's nice
whoo there's a surfer of awfully high
tech stuff for the year 2001 I think
this is Oh give me a circuit board Oh
give me a circuit board
okay I'm these other boards this looks
damaged that looks damaged how do these
even get damaged in the first place I
don't know I don't know I imagine I
don't need to try them because the one
that works correctly is going to look
pristine probably when we got here
um yeah thanks oh this is way out I need
to go back in there let me just double
time I didn't check everything
so just to be thorough we got here a
drawer oh I remember what goes ahh
he talked to Swanson of me and I recall
every single squirming without combo it
was ear slighted inflection in a tone
bit suggested she no longer give a yeah
I don't trust you I just let your
fiction 65 my news doctor would she
think that
haha oh yeah we share the same history
Oh shallow and I are history I recall I
recall the day of my birth aha of
September 1964 3.46 9 9 3 4 1 2
recurring minutes past nine oh you're
crazy I remember my mother looking
surprised as I poked my head out into
the world with a fist yeah this is crazy
you need a security registered palm
something I can provide you needed at
the library yeah so give me your palm I
reach when I became infected by those
mindless zombies I split off from the
others and secured myself here ha ha
I cannot leave y'all take your drawer
nonetheless and we'll need a hand I will
not bring me a saw oh no kiss I recall
see ha ha ha stay here three hours ago
will climate change of 10 degrees over
the past 1 million years together walk
east and take the first door on your
walk east there are must Oh God he's
like you like what you get in my eyes
every bound together are we truly a we
ah are we simply an eye with two faces
ah I am no monkey oh shut up shut up
okay I need to find a saw fine okay I
think there was a storage room all right
I think that voice is gonna be talking
to me throughout the whole game
that's a storage room maybe storage is
five but I'm a chicken school do that
here what's in here I've been here
nevermind nevermind sorry about that
storage storage storage library yeah
storage armory oh yeah
Oh give me some awk bullets give me some
guns
I'll give me a gun Oh give me a some
sort of weapon a pickaxe or something
beat these monsters all yeah saw this
one about a rusty shot that just makes
me oh oh oh no oh give me some throw at
him oh oh yeah oh you are close at door
yeah you don't want to face me from yes
I'll bring it on I'll bring it on I am
so ready for you I'm ready oh I'm ready
come on oh yeah get out of here ugly Oh
what's wrong with your Oh
why are you so naked so very naked oh so
very naked
a lost yari ah he's got a weapon yeah
oh nothing oh you see me are too bad oh
so great oh what's that oh you don't
want to open to me you're so tiny and
puny how are you even a threat
I even a threat answer is you're not get
in there oh good good good it has been
precisely 12 days 11 hours 39 minutes
and twelve point four seconds since
something good laughs oh you're weird
Oh what uh Wow Wow Oh
Faysal is wrong what the hell did you
even need the song give me the song oh
man I've done I does it
dang it god damn it Oh circuit board
circuit board game go get away
Oh get away Oh aah Oh close close close
aah aah so creepy
I'll put the circuit board in I'll put
it in print pic pic pic oh come on
ah oh you are oh oh I don't have time
for this now of course I know oh oh I
gotta trap him somehow I'll get him in
here press the button I saw button oh
wow Oh
get out of here Oh get out of here oh
yeah oh yeah oh [ __ ]
my congratulations so go honestly I mean
well uh I was only joking about the come
get him ding oh oh I got him celebrate
with some nice relaxing sighs oh sure oh
I'm sure I saw some anthrax light around
as well oh hey you I hate your voice in
my head I'm the only voice in John's
head get out
right transfer transfer oh look at this
I'm a tech pros oh yeah okay files
dreamer MN tools comes papa
Oh fine I gotta pick and choose Bob got
a note manual oh I saw a manual didn't I
I saw manual manual remember I remember
him I remember a circuit board ed I open
these drawers I think I did my glow
stick the batteries last like two
seconds on my flashlight yep they're
already gone
Oh was it so dark alleys in anyway Oh
Manuel Manuel Manuel oh yeah oh yeah
let's see boot network interface
required circuit cards boot collates
basic disk drive this is the Vince okay
all right okay circuit setup disc info
we're locator oh man oh man this is
annoying
do I have to memorize all these ok ok go
circuit setup disc info I even let the
order was just on there hang out I guess
see this what's going on part you see
notes and button
and okay oh I get it I got it I gotta
take certain programs stick this card in
the boot networking interface oh shut up
guy okay all right Cole eights basic
disk drive and hardware configuration
data okay what do I need
okay circuit setup require to get any
programmer okay I need that and I need
disk drive so disk info and hardware
okay
first three these three first okay oh
yeah oh yeah oh great oh great oh great
Oh yep oh yeah done Boop get out of here
get in there booty boot boot oh yeah did
that do it did that happen
what happened did anything that were
there more cards in there do I need more
cards probably probably why did that guy
even want me to get him a saw
oh man is what do you throw at me Oh
what is that uh I got Devon all right
we're there more cards in here I kind of
look kind of was in a hurry
good yep oh oh yeah so smart roars let
me save again opera jewelry yep all
right may never get used to that
I'm used to it I was used to it the
first time batteries
oh yeah
every one of these ha your nope wrong
empty nothing as always ah there we go
okay blue card oh yeah and I got a
color-coded cards don't I I hope I got
that boot one right that's read write
read read all year is the blue blue
chunk is like doom ah shut up
life is so oh I don't care I don't care
I don't care I'm ignoring you Han oh oh
you are so annoying
okay Network I'm just gonna need the
circuit setup and then just communicate
communication communication uh let's see
okay latest security programs okay
communication it got this got this
socket protocol firewall and
okay okay I think it's just a next the
first one in the next few okay let's try
that Bank
go go go go angle come back ah screw you
how about not this one net locator that
sounds good
oh yeah oh so great on the best oh yeah
alright there we go
okay and the last one oh shut up guy I'm
not letting you out let me tip video BAM
sip so big oh so smart like ah level 99
tech guy oh yeah
now what do I do get off get in there
get farther in yeah aerial all the way
in deeper
ah okay Wow something no what did it do
how did it do anything isn't there
supposed to be like a victory flash
something maybe oh oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah what's up there oh I win okay I'm
gonna pause it here thank you so much
for watching actually know let me hit
the save doohickey let me let me add
lemon lemonade my never knew let me Oh
poop alright uh thank you so much for
watching guys and I will see you next
time and let's play penumbra the Black
Plague bye bye